what house like I got missed that gold
bat ball going for it going for it
good work Wow all right whoa whoa ring
of that random ran back in mmm
go go go go go go go Canada it's your
birthday
we're gonna party like it's your 150th
birthday I mean it's a big deal here
folks and we are celebrating Canada's
big one
five oh hello I'm pretty excited about
it I hope you guys are too and we have
an awesome recipe today for a canada
vegan ice cream flight don't really have
a great name for it but when you see it
you're going to want to eat it because
it is so much fun and it looks super
fancy and complicated but honestly it
could not be more simple so let's do
this
all right kids so it takes a few steps
and a little bit of patience but trust
me it's going to be worth it so what
I've done here is I've just taken like a
little loaf pan and I've lined it both
ways I've got some going out this way
like little little like panty liner
wings and when going in this to sway
that way when you want to get get it out
it's a specific kind of lifting action
as you can see I've just taken some
leftover cardboard from like a box like
a a cereal box and wrap it up in a
little bit of more of that plastic wrap
and the key is to cut these pieces of
cardboard so that they fit lengthwise
you need to kind of get into your loaf
pan like that you see that this is like
the inch on either side you want to make
sure you're not getting too far into the
center helps you're going to lose the
space book quite so now we're going to
make our coconut ice cream spread or in
this case for pink but wet edge we're
going to just go with it
so I've got some that beautiful coconut
ice cream going into the Vitamix here so
delicious
this auctioneers lit off
slender not not plugged in sometimes
that's important round two now at this
point you can start to see the color and
I feel like we could add a little more
pink action all right get in there
that's what we're looking for okay this
is where know you make all the weather
women at the barbecue super yellow
secure your cake making skills so you're
going to press the pink ice cream down
the side of your cake hacker down mover
out now what I usually say is want to
make sure the maintain some distance on
either side you can grab like a little
bowl or something something to shove in
there once so here's like the cute
little battle see
so as you can see got the situation
going on I'm just going to pop this in
the freezer to let it set up so that we
can get the set to put in there and just
a moment
so we have a seedless watermelon alright
so you're just going to get them into
kind of nice dangerous as you can see
nice little shape to the slices so like
that alright now what we're going to do
degrees coffees adorable little Canadian
flag cookie cutters I thought that that
like my love local bulk store is multi
different imitating suffice or kitchen
supply store they're super cute also
Amazon has like a bird thing so a great
type of check so I'm going to do is I'm
going to take my cutter and just cut out
little shape in my water not
all right we are back and ready for
surgery so I have frozen the pink side
we're going to very carefully I could
just remove this
so I'm just going to line our mayfleet
all around the center put my coconut ice
cream around it so we get the wife to
get our little nice leaf and we have our
pink strip on the side Rock Canadian
flag Oh Canada
well there you have it folks I hope you
have an amazing Canada Day to all of my
Canadian viewers if you like this video
be sure to give it a thumbs up leave me
a comment below but you're gonna be
making for Canada today subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abbey's kitchen